I honestly lost count of how many people
made bargains and didn't live up to
their side of them things that go boom
Gotham season 4 episode 10 I was a
little nervous going to this woman
because let the meat pie was so good I
worried that there was gonna be you know
a dip because I happened sometimes you
ever really yeah the next one can't
measure up to it this did not have that
sort of time off a cliff this was oh
this was really good I like with my
intro I brought I brought that up
because I think there might have been on
just a little bit too much Oh what will
make you this deal ha ha not really and
I'm not gonna like that happen maybe
once it or maybe two too many times
actually but it oh this was a lot of fun
um reminder I know I do not do spoiler
free so here we go penguin yes so much
yes they're doing a really good job this
season of making it clear that you know
he's got his weaknesses same ones he's
always had he's overly emotional and he
can be easily manipulated on that level
but this episode also reminds everybody
the people in the show and the people
watching what makes him dangerous is
that as much as you can manipulate him
by his emotions
you still can't really predict him all
that well up to a point but eventually
he's gonna do something that is not what
you thought he was gonna do it all and
this emphasizes that really well it was
a great sort of pudding Sophia on the
back foot as well she's growing on me
I'm starting to kinda get over the fact
that they made the Sophia Falcone design
that I love from the comics into a more
standard attractive woman well I'm kind
of getting over there because this she
is working the manipulation really well
especially like I love how she turns on
a dime she seems to know when to switch
up and went to do this I they they may
have started to push credibility
credibility credibility
I can speak slightly with how much she
was manipulating like the fact that she
was that she had Martine Lian that she
was planning that Payne would would
torture her and that she would use this
specific guy who she had information
like it was a few steps too many that
she claimed to have control of but it
sort of it took the curse of it at the
end that penguin just did something that
she did not expect whatsoever so I think
it kind of it makes it okay that maybe
she was overly she had too much control
about the situation cuz all of it was
gone by the end so that worked really
well I'm liking that Barbara seems to be
getting angry which is good cause it's
bringing out the crazy in her a little
bit again you can see it in the eyes um
cuz when she was kind of in a more
controlled situation she was she was a
bit too reined in this season but I got
I got the head look when she said she
was gonna break penguins beak in half
I'm like that's that's the Barbara Kean
I love I'm starting to feel a little bit
bummed out about Selina lately i but I
was originally really game for her
joining up with Barbara and and with
Tabitha but she she just seems to kind
of just be there I mean it really feels
like it's it's Barbara running the show
and Tabitha and Selina are just along
for the ride happen I don't mind so much
because she was paired for about with
Barbara for so long anyway Selina I kind
of I feel like we're missing her own
agenda her own sense of agency she's uh
she's feeling a little background right
now which I'm not loving the new twist
with Pig are interesting I I have to
admit I know professor Pig a little bit
from the comics I don't know him deeply
so I don't know how much of this is
stuff they're making up of stuff they're
pulling from the comics I don't care
either way it's fun I and it was a great
opener with him well killing a guy with
a record nice work
but beyond that you know how
the punch and then these jaw does
something weirdly just snaps it back
into places like what is going on and we
start to get the details I'm like I I'm
also I I'm pleasantly surprised that
we've got more to get out of pig because
I kind of assumed well he got arrested
last I was over probably not gonna see
him again for a while but instead here
he is right again I'm really enjoying
their how they're balancing Lee right
now with her getting her footing in this
very dangerous criminal world that she's
now operating in but still maintaining
her morals her mission her desire to
help people and I think they're they're
balancing that in a way that's really
interesting I'm finding Edie interesting
in terms of these revelations about you
know okay yeah you had a physical issue
briefly but at this point it's just it's
all in your head and then as soon as he
realized that in like maybe he could
even start to be okay again there's
there's the Riddler and it's cheesy but
it's cheesy in the way that I like on
Gotham so that worked for me and I think
you know Gordon I mean I'm admiring his
resolve in trying to deal with Sophia
Falcone and you know she's obviously
been playing him just as well as she was
playing penguin except that I think she
can probably continue to play Jim
O'Hara's penguin I think she realizes
that was a bad idea I'm not gonna try
and do that again
the whole thing with penguin and Martine
in the car I didn't necessarily call the
explosion but I had the thought when he
first got my team back he's like he's
not gonna stab the kid is he and I'm
glad I'm glad he did but I did have the
thought and then as soon as he said I'm
not gonna let you use him as leverage
for me and I'm like he's gonna blow that
car up boom which oh man that was a good
that was a good moment even when I
thought it was real and having and
normally it's the sort of thing that I
would get annoyed being like oh but it
was
real they were sneaking and whatnot and
normally that would annoy me kind of
works for me here though because it
still plays to the truth of this version
of penguins emotions and his attachments
and the fact that he probably wouldn't
be able to do that but it's really
important that his enemies think he
could so that that did ultimately work
even though on paper it's something that
I probably wouldn't like usually but
that was well executed Doug all that I'm
not sure there's too much else to talk
about overall was just a really good
really fun episode it was uh I think I
think let them eat pie it was a little
bit better than this what it's still
it's close it's right up there at that
level like my only real complain about
is this Selina as I mentioned and yeah
man this shows fun so those are my
thoughts on things that go boom the
latest episode of Gotham have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to council of geeks podcast
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio I'm also one half of the bunch
like your girl podcast that is available
on fire and water podcast calm as part
of the fire and water podcast network
links for all this stuff is gonna be
down into the description and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]